foreign
let's go to Craig in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Craig how can we help
hey there guys thanks for taking my call
I appreciate it you bet for you guys do
that daily basis you guys are helping a
lot of people so
um so my question is prone to work my
wife and I have heard the plan a few
years ago we're now in uh baby steps
four five and six
um and part of that is one of our
daughters a freshman in college so we're
helping cash flow that
um for our questions we're trying to
dump extra money into the house we have
three vehicles that are a little bit
older because we didn't want to upgrade
while we're paying off that so my wife
is thinking maybe we should start
putting some money into a fund aside to
save for cars or as I want to just keep
tackling the house and I guess the
question is is like how do you figure
out at this point which is you know and
that is not a right answer but what
direction to go well I'm going to jump
in first because this is non-financial
advice so I'll let my my co-host the
financial expert weigh in but I'm going
to weigh in as a dude who's been married
24 and a half years
you got the money you have the income
and the discipline
when Mama says that she wants to uh open
up a fund to replace her car you need to
go okay sweetheart we're gonna start
that I'll have a new budget to you in
the morning if you if you want to
correct keep driving an older car and
just pile money the house that's that's
your call
I think I'd start funding a new car for
your wife that's the uh see I told you
it wasn't Financial advice now you got
to make that work Rachel fantastic
Financial advice it's relational first
pal that's what I'm looking out for you
right now well I was gonna say Craig I
mean you don't have to replace all three
cars at the exact same time so find the
one that's that's either just needed
I was gonna give an A or B option
there's no option that is needed
or her car B uh and just do you have you
guys run any number since she's the one
that asks obviously I know we're kind of
joking with her but does she know what
she wants like do you guys have you run
any numbers of like the type of car she
wants or anything just it's more just an
idea I mean we just no I mean it's for a
specific cards though we talked about
pricing like we we're kind of thinking
if we could probably get something
decent for around 15 000 so that's kind
of what we're planning to do but we do
have a part a little bit older more of a
beater car that my daughter has in
school and the last inspection there was
concerns over the frame uh maybe not
passing that inspection so then I'm
thinking uh hey can you move your Craig
can you move your phone a little bit
we're kind of coming into now sorry
all right let's keep going yeah so the
third car is the daughter's beater that
she's using at college
hey College in our last inspection did
mentioned that the frame is starting to
rot and they didn't think it would pass
the next inspection so the real reason
so now we're trying to look in her car
we're on my wife's car runs but
it's not perfect he he can't reverse up
pills because of a select transmission
problems
buddy this is your intervention your
wife's in a car that won't go in reverse
man
I thank you I think you need to buy or a
car I think
yeah you guys are killing me no
so no for real though on a tactical
level Craig I would say okay yeah 15 000
for your wife's car daughter with the
bad frame beater she can hold off first
she can get six eight months she can
bike around College these kids man these
kids what do they expect get a bicycle
oh my gosh Craig I'm here for you okay
so so yeah I would say Okay 15 000 if
that's what it is figure out how much
you can sell hers for Kelly Blue Book it
figure out the difference and then you
create a sinking fund and then every
month still putting a little bit of
extra towards the house but slow the
house down then say okay how many months
do we have to save up to get that
whatever the difference is let's say
it's eight grand I don't know what it
would be well it can't reverse so you're
probably you may not get a lot of money
for her car I don't know uh but just to
say okay figure out the math have a game
plan have a sinking fund which means in
the budget for from this month on Craig
October through however long it's going
to take you guys to say put some money
aside for her car and then we can you
can check out the daughter's car after
that um but that's what I would do but
you're still putting extra towards the
house you're going to just slow it down
he wants to go full-fledged house and I
love that uh but I would pull back on
the house some still add some extra
money towards the mortgage so you're
still putting extra towards the house
but pull back a little bit to save up
and get your wife a car if he doesn't
get her a car he's going to be sleeping
outside of this house he wants to pay
off so badly I'm just telling you I'm
just here for you Craig you're a good
guy you're crushing it I love the
gazelle intensity your wife's gonna love
us oh I know she's gonna hear this calm
thing hi somebody should send her the
link to that I'm going to be her
favorite host ever I'm like come on man
all right good stuff hey Craig you're
awesome uh you guys are gonna get there
uh you really are and you've been
disciplined at this point good on you
but now is time I mean when the car
won't go in gear it's probably a sign
that it's time to begin to replace it